GOING TO JOIN US RIGHT NOW AND I
GUESS IF WE HAVE TO GIVE WAY,
NOBODY BETTER THAN THE
PRESIDENT.
SENATOR, THINK HE WAS ALWAYS FOR
BEING WITH US.
JOINING US NOW LIVE.
HE’S IN THE WHITE HOUSE AS WE
SPEAK, THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
MR. PRESIDENT, THANK YOU, SIR,
FOR JOINING US.
APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE.
>> President Trump: THANK YOU,
SEAN.
>> Sean: LET’S START WITH THE
BIG NEWS TODAY.
KAMALA HARRIS, YOUR INITIAL
THOUGHTS.
>> President Trump: WELL, IF
YOU READ THE VARIOUS POLITICAL
PUNDITS, YOU WOULD’VE SAID MAYBE
THAT WOULD’VE BEEN THE ONE A LOT
OF PEOPLE THINK IT’S A DANGEROUS
CHOICE.
SHE IS THE MOST PERSON
SUPPOSEDLY IN THE SENATE.
THAT’S PRETTY LIBERAL.
BUT SHE SUPPOSED TO BE THE MOST.
I’M NOT SURE THAT’S WHAT THE
COUNTRY WANTS.
I THINK IF IT IS, WE’VE GOT
PROBLEMS.
I WOULD BE SURPRISED IF IT IS.
SHE WANTS TO RAISE TAXES.
SHE WANTS TO GET RID OF YOUR
SECOND AMENDMENT.
NO GUNS FOR PROTECTION, NO
NOTHING.
SHE IS VERY STRONG ON THE
SECOND AMENDMENT, GETTING RID OF
IT.
VERY BAD TO THE MILITARY.
SHE WANTS TO CUT THE MILITARY.
SHE WANTS TO CUT SPENDING FOR
THE MILITARY AND THE VETS AND
YOU KNOW, I DON’T QUITE GET THE
CHOICE.
BUT WE WILL HAVE IT OUT HERE WE
HAVE A GREAT VICE PRESIDENT
NAMED MIKE PENCE AND HE WILL
TAKE CARE OF BUSINESS JUST LIKE
HE DID THE LAST TIME AGAINST A
DIFFERENT CANDIDATE.
>> Sean: VICE PRESIDENT PENCE
WILL EXCLUSIVELY JOIN US ON THIS
PROGRAM TOMORROW.
LET’S GO THROUGH SOME OF THE
SPECIFICS.
ONE OF THE FIRST DEMOCRATS TO
COSPONSOR, I CALL HIM BOLSHEVIK
BERNIE, BERNIE SANDERS.
HE USED TO BE AN OUTLIER IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, WAY OUTSIDE
THE DEMOCRATIC MAINSTREAM.
SHE COSPONSORED NOT ONLY HIS
SINGLE-PAYER MEDICARE FOR ALL
WHICH WOULD BE ANYWHERE
ESTIMATES FROM 32 TO
$54 TRILLION.
SHE WANTED TO ELIMINATE PRIVATE
HEALTH INSURANCE EVEN FOR
AMERICANS THAT LIKE THEIR PLAN.
THAT SOUNDS EXTREME, SERVE.
>> President Trump: WELL,
THAT’S 180 MILLION PEOPLE.
THEY LOVE THEIR PLAN, NOT LIKE
IT.
THEY DON’T WANT TO TAKE IT AWAY
AND IF YOU GOING TO SOCIALIZED
MEDICINE WHICH IS WHAT SHE WANTS
AND SUPPORT STRONGLY AND THAT’S
WHAT BIDEN WANTS ULTIMATELY.
NOT QUITE HAVE A CHOICE BECAUSE
HIS PARTY WANTS IT.
THE PEOPLE THAT REALLY CONTROL
THE PARTY.
HE WILL NEVER CONTROL THE PARTY.
THEY WANTED.
THAT MEANS YOU’RE DESTROYING
SOMETHING THAT 180 MILLION
PEOPLE LOVE.
THEY HAVE A PLAN THAT THEY
REALLY LIKE.
THAT’S A VERY HARD THING TO DO,
VERY HARD THING TO DO WITH MY
THE WAY I HAVE TO SAY, LARRY AND
LEO AND JANINE AND YOUR GREAT
SENATOR, JOHN KENNEDY, WHO
WAS FANTASTIC.
KARL ROVE HAS BEEN SO GREAT.
YOU KNOW KARL AND I HAD OUR
DISPUTES PREVIOUSLY.
WE LIKE EACH OTHER A LOT.
HE’S BEEN GREAT.
KARL WAS GREAT TONIGHT AND I
WILL SAY THAT WAS SOME PRECAST I
HAD ON.
THAT WAS VERY IMPRESSIVE.
THANK YOU.
>> Sean: I GUESS WE CALL THAT
THE OPENING ACT, MR. PRESIDENT.
>> President Trump: THEY WERE
GOOD.
THEY WERE GOOD.
>> Sean: I’VE TALKED A LOT
ABOUT THIS AND WHEN YOU WERE A
CANDIDATE I ASKED YOU MANY, MANY
TIMES ABOUT THE NEED FOR AMERICA
TO BECOME ENERGY INDEPENDENT.
YOU WENT FORWARD WITH THE
KEYSTONE XL PIPELINE.
THE DAKOTA PIPELINE.
YOU’VE OPENED AND WARREN FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN 75 YEARS AMERICA
IS NOW ENERGY INDEPENDENT AND WE
ARE NOW ALSO, IT’S BEEN A LONGER
PERIOD OF TIME, THE LARGEST
PRODUCER OF ENERGY IN THE ENTIRE
WORLD.
COSPONSOR IN THE U.S. SENATE OF
THIS RADICAL GREEN NEW DEAL.
JOE BIDEN HAS ALREADY PLEDGED
TRILLIONS OF TAXPAYER DOLLARS
FOR THAT PLAN.
ALL I SEE IS IT WOULD ELIMINATE
THE LIFEBLOOD OF THE WORLD’S
ECONOMY, AMERICA’S ECONOMY.
IN THE NEXT TEN YEARS ACCORDING
TO THE ORIGINAL PLAN THAT SHE
WAS A COSPONSOR OF.
HOW DO YOU SEE THAT IN TERMS OF
THE GEOPOLITICAL STRATEGIC EVEN
DEFENSE OF THIS COUNTRY?
THAT TO ME IS A CRUCIAL PROGRAM
THAT IS SCARY.
TO GO BACK TO ENERGY DEPENDENCE
IS SCARY TO ME.
>> President Trump: WE ARE NOW
ENERGY INDEPENDENT FOR THE FIRST
TIME I GUESS EVER.
WE ARE VERY POWERFUL ON ENERGY.
WHEN WE HAVE THE PANDEMIC HIT US
FROM CHINA, IT SHOULD’VE NEVER
HAPPENED.
THEY SHOULD’VE NEVER LET THAT
HAPPEN.
THERE WAS OBVIOUSLY A LOT OF
ENERGY AROUND.
WE SAVED IT.
I SAVED IT.
WE CALLED RUSSIA,
PRESIDENT PUTIN.
WE CALLED THE KING OF
SAUDI ARABIA.
THEY CUT 10 MILLION BARRELS OF
OIL A DAY.
WE SAVED THE ENERGY.
NOW WE ARE AT $41 A BARREL.
MORE IMPORTANTLY FOR THE PEOPLE
DRIVING CARS, WE ARE AROUND $2
AND EVEN LESS A GALLON AND IT’S
FANTASTIC.
SHE’S AGAINST PETROLEUM.
SHE IS AGAINST FRACKING.
SO IS BIDEN.
THAT MEANS YOU CAN’T WIN BACK
TEXAS.
YOU CAN’T WIN PENNSYLVANIA.
YOU CAN’T WIN OKLAHOMA OR
NORTH DAKOTA OR MANY OTHER
STATES THAT IT ALSO MEANS YOUR
ELECTRIC BILLS WOULD GO UP
LITERALLY BY TEN TIMES.
IT WOULDN’T BE EVEN SUSTAINABLE.
IF THEY WENT WITH THIS CRAZY,
IT’S LIKE CHILD’S PLAY.
IF THEY WENT WITH THE SO-CALLED
GREEN NEW DEAL, YOU’RE TALKING
ABOUT A CATASTROPHIC FOR THE
COUNTRY.
PROBABLY HAVE TO CLOSE 20 TO 25%
OF YOUR BUSINESSES EVEN TO
QUALIFY AND THEY WOULDN’T
FUNCTION PROPERLY BECAUSE WE
DON’T HAVE THAT KIND OF ENERGY.
IT’S CRAZY.
THEY CAN’T POWER -- WE HAVE
THESE MASSIVE PLANTS, SOME OF
WHICH AND MANY OF WHICH ARE
BEING BUILT UNDER ME.
THE CAR COMPANIES ARE MOVING
BACK FROM JAPAN AND FROM OTHER
COUNTRIES, COMING IN FROM
GERMANY.
THEY’RE COMING BACK TO AMERICA.
FIRST TIME IN 42 YEARS.
YOU CAN’T EVEN THINK ABOUT
FIRING UP THOSE PLANTS WITH THE
KIND OF THINGS THEY’RE TALKING
ABOUT.
WIND IS NICE.
IT’S NICE.
BUT IT’S, IT CAUSES TREMENDOUS
ENVIRONMENT OF PROBLEMS.
HOME VALUES GOING WAY DOWN.
IF YOU SEE A WINDMILL AND HEAR A
WINDMILL, YOUR HOME IS WORTH
HALF OR LESS THAN HALF.
IT KILLS ALL THE BIRDS.
THE WHOLE THING IS CRAZY WHAT
THEY WANT TO DO AND THEY’LL
DESTROY THE COUNTRY.
WE BUILT THE GREATEST AND IF YOU
SEE WHAT HAPPENED, WE HAVE THE
GREATEST ECONOMY AND HISTORY OF
THE WORLD.
BETTER THAN CHINA BY FAR.
WE WERE LAPPING THEM AND THEN
ALL OF A SUDDEN WHEN THE PLAGUE
CAME IN, WE ARE TO CLOSE IT
DOWN.
WE SAVED MILLIONS OF LIVES AND
NOW WERE OPENING IT UP AND
RESETTING RECORDS AND YOU SEE
THAT STOCK PRICES TODAY, THE
MARKETS, THE NASDAQ IS HIGHER
THAN IT EVER WAS.
THE DOW IS JUST ABOUT READY.
IT’S RIGHT AT ALMOST THE SAME
LEVEL.
WHO WOULD HAVE BELIEVED THAT IN
THE MIDDLE OF A PANDEMIC, WHICH
WE ARE SOON GOING TO HAVE
VACCINES AND THERAPEUTICS.
IT’S GOING TO BE, IT’S GOING TO
ALL BE GOOD NEXT YEAR.
WERE GOING TO HAVE ONE OF THE
GREATEST YEARS WE’VE EVER HAD IF
IT ISN’T BLOWN OUT THE WINDOW
BY TRIPLING AND QUADRUPLING
TAXES AND REGULATIONS.
>> Sean: LET ME SPECIFICALLY
GO INTO THE ISSUE AND IT WAS A
SIGNATURE ISSUE FOR YOU IN 2016.
BUILDING THE WALL.
UPDATE US ON THAT PART.
IT WAS A HEAVY LIFT AND YOU HAD
TO FIND A WAY TO REALLOCATE
FUNDS FROM THE DEFENSE
DEPARTMENT AND ELSEWHERE.
BUT YOU HAVE TWO CANDIDATES NOW
THAT SUPPORT AMNESTY.
KAMALA HARRIS SUPPORTS SANCTUARY
CITIES.
THE SANCTUARY STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
WANTS TO ELIMINATE I.C.E.
YOUR REACTION TO THE VERY
DIFFERENT POSITIONS THAT YOU
HAVE ON THIS VERY KEY ISSUE AND
AN ISSUE THAT HAS DEFINED YOUR
FIRST CAMPAIGN AND IS A BIG
ISSUE STILL TODAY.
>> President Trump: SO THE
WALL AS WELL UNDER CONSTRUCTION.
WE HAVE 281 MILES UP.
281 MILES, ONE OF THE REASONS
THE BORDER NUMBERS ARE SO GOOD
BECAUSE WHEREVER IT’S BUILT,
NOBODY COMES THROUGH.
YOU CAN’T GET THROUGH IT UNLESS
YOU’RE A CLIMBER OF
MOUNT EVEREST.
THAT’S ABOUT IT.
YOU HAVE TO BE OF THAT TALENT.
WE HAVE 281 MILES.
THE REST IS BEING BUILT BY THE
END OF THE YEAR IT’LL BE MOSTLY
FINISHED.
WE MAY ADD ANOTHER 50 MILES.
IT WAS UNPLANNED FOR IN CERTAIN
AREAS THAT ARE LITTLE BIT TOUGH.
WILL MAKE THAT DETERMINATION.
THE WALL IS BUILT.
YOU DON’T HEAR ABOUT THAT
ANYMORE.
THAT WAS THE BIGGEST TOPIC.
AS SOON AS I WON, THE DEMOCRATS
STOP TALKING ABOUT IT WHEN THEY
STOPPED, THEIR COPARTNER STOPS,
THAT’S THE MEDIA, THE CORRUPT
MEDIA, THE FAKE NEWS, SEE DON’T
HEAR ABOUT IT SO THE WALL IS
GOING UP AND HAVING A TREMENDOUS
IMPACT AND IT’S EXACTLY WHAT THE
BORDER PATROL WANTED.
WE DECIDED TOGETHER.
IT’S EXACTLY WHAT THEY WANTED.
THEY WANTED TO STEEL, CONCRETE,
AND REBAR.
I SAID HOW ABOUT ONE?
THEY SAID WE’D ALL THREE FOR
STRENGTH AND FOR OTHER REASONS.
SECURITY.
SO THAT AND IF YOU LOOK AT I
SEE, THESE PEOPLE ARE
INCREDIBLE.
THEY ARE TAKING OUT THOUSANDS OF
MS-13 GANG MEMBERS, THESE ARE
THE ROUGHEST THERE ARE.
ANYWHERE THEY ARE, THEY ARE
CRAZY.
THEY ARE CRAZY.
WE ARE EITHER BRINGING THE BACK
TO THEIR COUNTRY OR WE ARE
PUTTING THEM IN JAIL.
IN SOME CASES WE REALLY HAVE TO
PUT THEM IN JAIL.
WE DON’T WANT TO HAVE TO PAY FOR
THEM FOR THE NEXT 50 YEARS BUT
WE DON’T WANT TO TAKE A CHANCE
THEY ARE SO VIOLENT.
THEY KILL PEOPLE WITH KNIVES
BECAUSE IT’S MORE PAINFUL ANY GO
SLOWER.
THAT’S WHAT THEY SAY, IT GOES
SLOWER AND IT’S MORE PAINFUL.
WE ARE TAKING THEM OUT BY THE
THOUSANDS.
GUATEMALA, YOU LOOK AT
GUATEMALA, HONDURAS,
EL SALVADOR.
THESE ARE COUNTRIES THAT
WOULDN’T TAKE PEOPLE BACK.
TREMENDOUS PROBLEMS CAME TO OUR
COUNTRY.
THEY WOULDN’T TAKE THEM BACK.
NOW THEY TAKE THEM BACK.
YOU KNOW, WE ARE PAYING THEM FOR
YEARS HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS A YEAR, RIDICULOUSLY.
I SAID YOU MEAN WE’RE PAYING
THEM THE MONEY, WE DON’T -- WE
BRING THEM TO THE COUNTRY.
THEY WOULDN’T LET OUR PLANES
LAND.
BEFORE ME.
WHEN I GOT THERE I SAID THEY
WON’T DO THAT AND WE ARE NOT
GOING TO PAY THEM ANYMORE.
ONCE THEY SAID THAT WE STOP
PAYING THEM AND THEN ALL OF A
SUDDEN THEY TAKE THESE PEOPLE
BACK GLADLY VERY, VERY HAPPILY.
MEXICO HAS 27,000 OF THEIR
SOLDIERS ON THE SOUTHERN BORDER
AND PEOPLE AREN’T COMING IN NOW.
THEY DON’T GO PAST THE MEXICAN
SOLDIERS.
VERY, VERY FEW PEOPLE COMING
ILLEGALLY.
THAT’S HELPED OF COURSE BY THE
WALL.
WE HAVE MADE TREMENDOUS STRIDES.
WE LET PEOPLE COME IN LEGALLY.
WE WANT PEOPLE TO COME IN
THROUGH MERIT WHERE THEY CAN
HELP OUR COUNTRY, THEY CAN LOVE
OUR COUNTRY AND THAT’S WHAT’S
HAPPENING.
THE DEMOCRATS, I CALL THEM THE
RADICAL LEFT BECAUSE IF YOU LOOK
AT THE RACES, YOU LOOK AT SOME
OF THE RACES THAT ARE TAKING
PLACE, ALL OF THESE OLDER
MAINLINE DEMOCRATS ARE BEING
BEATEN BY RADICAL LEFT, I DON’T
KNOW, I GUESS YOU COULD SAY
ANARCHISTS IN A CERTAIN WAY.
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE WINNING
THESE RACES FOR THE DEMOCRATS,
ELIOT ENGEL, HE WAS A STAPLE
MANY, MANY YEARS, YOU KNOW WHO
I’M TALKING ABOUT.
A STAPLE FROM A VERY NICE PART
OF THE WORLD THAT’S GOING BAD ON
US, NEW YORK.
IT’S GOING BAD.
I LEFT THERE FOUR YEARS AGO.
IT WAS A WONDERFUL PLACE.
YOU COULD SEE SIGNS OF BADNESS
BUT IT WAS A WONDERFUL PLACE AND
NOW CRIME IS UP BY MANY, MANY
TIMES.
WHAT’S HAPPENING IN NEW YORK IS
SO HORRIBLE FOR OUR COUNTRY,
WHAT THEY’VE DONE, WHAT
MAYOR de BLASIO HAS DONE TO
THAT CITY AND A SHORT PERIOD OF
TIME IS HORRIBLE.
BUT YOU LOOK AT ELLIOTT ENGEL,
GETS BEATEN EASILY BY A RADICAL
LEFT AND THE DEMOCRATS, THAT’S
WHERE THEY ARE.
THEY DON’T WANT PETROLEUM.
THEY DON’T WANT
SECOND AMENDMENT.
THEY DON’T WANT RELIGION.
THEY DON’T WANT ANYTHING.
IT’S DISGRACEFUL.
>> Sean: LET ME GO, I PLEADED
THAT THE BEGINNING OF THE
PROGRAM, IS INTERESTING TO ME
THAT YOU WOULD TWEET ALMOST
WITHIN MINUTES TODAY THE AD
ABOUT KAMALA HARRIS AND DID YOU
HAVE AN INSTINCT THAT IT WAS
GOING TO BE KAMALA ARE PERHAPS
THE NAMES THAT HAVE BEEN
MENTIONED THE MOST.
DID YOU HAVE ADS PREPARED FOR
ALL OF THEM?
>> President Trump: KNOW BUT
WE HAVE SOME VERY TALENTED
PEOPLE.
IT WAS QUICK.
WE HAVE TALENTED PEOPLE.
I THOUGHT IT MIGHT BE HER.
IF YOU REMEMBER, SHE WAS GOING
TO DO VERY WELL.
SHE WAS ONE OF THE PEOPLE THAT
WAS PROJECTED TO HAVE A CHANCE
AT WINNING.
ALL SHE DID AS PEOPLE GOT TO
KNOW HER, SHE WENT DOWN.
SHE FINISHED AT 2%, PROBABLY
LESS THAN THAT AND SHE FLED.
REMEMBER HOW QUICKLY.
SHE SAID HORRIBLE THINGS ABOUT
BIDEN.
THE ONE THING I FELT HE COULDN’T
DO.
SHE TOOK WHAT SOME BUDDY SAID
ABOUT HER, SOME HORRIBLE THINGS
THAT WERE SAID ABOUT JOE AND SHE
WOMAN THAT SAID THEM.
THAT WAS A TERRIBLE STATEMENT
AND I SAID YOU KNOW JUST THAT
STATEMENT ALONE.
SHE MADE TERRIBLE STATEMENTS.
SHE ESSENTIALLY CALLED HIM A
RACIST.
AND OTHER THINGS THAT WERE VERY
BAD.
I SAID WE PROBABLY CAN’T PICK
HER BUT LET’S DO SOMETHING ON
HER BECAUSE PEOPLE WERE SAYING
IT COULD HAPPEN THEN WE HAD
OTHERS IN MIND ALSO.
WE HAD SOME OTHER CHOICES.
SHE WAS MY NUMBER ONE DRAFT
PICK.
SHE WAS THE ONE I THOUGHT WOULD